the anterior cruciate ligament or ACL is
one of the four main ligaments
connecting the femur to the tibia the
ACL provides stability as you move your
knee a torn ACL may occur if your knee
joint over rotates or if you receive a
direct blow to the front of your knee if
your ACL tears through completely your
doctor may recommend surgery to repair
it before your procedure you will
receive either spinal anesthesia which
will numb your body from the chest down
or general anesthesia which will put you
to sleep for the duration of the
procedure during this arthroscopic
procedure your surgeon will make a few
incisions around your knee through which
he or she will insert surgical
instruments including a camera the
camera will transmit images to a TV
monitor which the surgeon will view
during the procedure first your surgeon
will remove the remaining portions of
your torn ACL from your knee
then your surgeon will remove part of
your patellar tendon to use as the graft
or obtained donor tissue your surgeon
will create attachment points for the
graft by drilling a small tunnel in the
end of your tibia
then another at the end of your femur
your surgeon will place one end of the
patellar tendon graft in the tibial
tunnel then he or she will pull the
graft up through the knee joint and into
the femoral tunnel to create a new ACL
tendon finally your surgeon will place
small screws in the tunnels at either
end of the new ACL to hold it in place
over the next six to eight weeks bone
growth will fill in these tunnels
further stabilizing the graft
at the end of the procedure your doctor
will remove the instruments and close
the incisions this procedure typically
lasts two to two-and-a-half hours
after the procedure you will go to the
recovery room for two to three hours and
then go home you will likely need a knee
brace and crutches for one to four weeks
supervised physical therapy should begin
two or three days after surgery and
continue for six to ten weeks after this
time continue with self-directed therapy
as long as needed
it takes about nine months for a
reconstructed ACL to fully heal
you should avoid contact sports racket
sports and other sports that require
rapid Direction changes until you obtain
approval from your physician